wenn der herd an turbine mit dem ziel
der hng
wenn die an das verzerrt
hier freunde wir sind gerade tatsächlich
irgendwo im kompletten irgendwo
angelangt wir sind gerade bei der kern
mir warm und werden hier jetzt gleich
quadfahren gehen vielleicht
bogenschießen machen und so weiter was
gibt es da zu lachen übrigens ich bin
hier zusammen mit max hier ist max
partie für präsident werden jedenfalls
schon jetzt den ganzen stoff gopro et
cetera oder material in ordnung zusammen
alle quad fahren gehen
gerade oben auf dem berg angekommen
überall da unten angefangen
es ist einfach weg
wir sind jetzt fertig mit dem quad
fahren es war halt tatsächlich einfach
richtig geil ich finde ich liebe dieses
quartal war das hat richtig spaß gemacht
jetzt gerade laufen max und ich hier da
hinten ist unser hotel das cliff hotel
wir laufen jetzt gerade in richtung
sonnenuntergang
das ist halt echt genauso wie ich mir
eigentlich wales vorgestellt aber
einfach so unglaublich geile
landschaften also das sieht man ja hier
auch nochmal so unglaublichen 1 ich weiß
nicht ich kann das gar nicht in worte
fassen das ist einfach ich bin ja eher
so der typ der lieber landschaften hat
also riesige ich fand new york muss man
dahin aber ich bin viel lieber gerade
hier als irgendeiner großstadt und alter
gebt euch das mal das ist doch echt
nicht mehr normal hier wir sollten jetzt
aufpassen dass wir hier nicht
runterfallen aber was ist das bitte was
geht
und der sonnenuntergang ist halt
tatsächlich so nice ich meine
schaut euch das mal ein schon an
11freunde
wir sind echt man kann einfach echt
schick kommt man sofort unter man denkt
dass man meine frau ist auf jeden fall
perfekt man denkt auf einmal irgendwie
so bei alles nach ich habe keine ahnung
warum und warum ich das katrin hater ist
wachsen
hey ich zeige euch jetzt nochmal den
sonnenuntergang so ein bisschen näher
und golfplatz nicht aufgefallen
normalerweise golf gespielt da hinten
ist auch sonst also davon wohl auch noch
zum strand gehen oder so aber das ist in
die komisch mal dass sie zu hause weder
die ölplattform wie kaputt gegangen das
ist ein bisschen crazy alles passt denn
ab hier mitglieder übelste
sonnenuntergang und hier steht junge wie
mein
es ist einfach anders kann man das nicht
beschreiben du hast auch einfach hier
auf der seite ist das meer und hier ist
einfach irgendwie so eine dritte da oben
gilt grad okay das jetzt einfach nichts
es ist einfach übels neues man einfach
zu allen seiten so mega meistens darf
hier vorne ist auch okay hier setzt
jetzt natürlich nicht
hier geht es auch nochmal weiter also
das wasser sieht vor allem so mega blaue
haus da und müssen